je m'attendais pas à ce succès n'est pas
du tout à ce que je reconnais que le
peuple martiniquais est assez changeant
mais néanmoins je savais que la cause
que nous défendions était une cause
juste
deuxièmement comme ceux qui ont décidé
de matelas candu 6 ils savent très bien
que c'est une cause perdue d'avancé
parce que la loi ne prévoit pas ça et
imaginons imagine rien ceci cela
d'ailleurs je suis le défenseur tous les
partis politiques mentent unitaire est
ce que moi me voyait demander au parti
progressiste martiniquais de choisir le
président du parti progressiste
martiniquais
ce n'est pas envisageable est-ce que
vous en rendez vous la semaine prochaine
à l'espace dd oui on aura changé vouloir
vous en faites pas mais je ne voudrais
voir pas ils ne l'ont pas changé leur
fusil d'épaulé
ce sera le même thème et vous aurez
surpris de le voir détermination